every two years we Americans celebrate
our freedom by getting a new phone and
agreeing to be locked in by a
multibillion-dollar wireless carrier
they trap us in pricey contracts with
hard to understand benefits while making
it incredibly hard to leave let alone
take our phone with us but there's a
surprisingly easy way to get out of here
unlocked phones are not bound to a
specific carrier with them you can
switch from say AT&T to t-mobile to
Cricket Wireless or even Europe's
Vodafone when you go on vacation
generally it does mean paying more for
your phone upfront but you can have your
pick of carriers and you can save more
money in the long run if your contract
is up here's how to make a break for it
step 1 get yourself an unlocked phone
you'll have to pay full price there's no
more subsidized pricing which the
carrier's really only gave you so you'd
sell your soul to them the good news is
that the price has come down on a lot of
the best unlocked Android phones take
the 64 gigabyte Moto X which is one of
my favourite phones it's $500 unlocked
the Moto G doesn't have his nicest
screen or camera but it costs only a
hundred and seventy nine dollars
Google's Nexus 5 cost 350 and the
exceptional oneplus one is just $300 you
won't find that sort of pricing on
iPhones an unlocked entry-level iPhone 6
cost 650 dollars but it should be in
theory easier to unlock old iPhones and
old smartphones through your carrier the
FCC has pushed carriers to unlock out of
contract phones ATT almost instantly
unlocked my out of contract iPhone 5 but
decline to unlock an iPhone 5s still in
contract and good luck trying to fight
it can I please speak to your manager
I bought the phone step to find a
service plan for your new unlocked phone
the best way to save money is by staying
away from those big carriers but first
some basics most unlock phones run on
the GSM network that means they're
compatible with AT&T and t-mobile
network they likely won't work on
Verizon or Sprint CDMA network although
some iPhone models work on both networks
smaller prepaid carriers actually use
those same networks too for instance
Cricket Wireless uses 18 T's Network and
metro pcs is on
t-mobile's but both charge less per
month for service I mean check this out
Cricket Wireless charges $45 for 2.5
gigabytes of data and unlimited talk and
text on 18 T's network 18 T charges $65
for about the same I've been using a
Cricket Wireless sim in the 1 plus for
the last week in New York and have been
totally satisfied with the service
performance but there's still plenty of
reasons to go with a big player and
t-mobile offers the best deal $60 for 3
gigabytes of LTE and perks like
international data and here's another
great thing if you go with one of the
smaller guys like cricket straight talk
or metro pcs you can just up and leave
it's empowering just to think about no
big carrier contracts are not gonna
vanish overnight but with affordable
unlocked phones and strong pricing
competition contracts seems stupid it's
a big step forward in getting the
wireless freedom we deserve